covid cases are rising sharp in
governments across europe are ratcheting
up the controls in our everyday lives
but some scientists from the uk and
elsewhere have now signed the great
barrington declaration warning that the
restrictions do
more harm than good they argue that the
risk of death is up to a thousand
times lower in the young than the old
yet the whole of society
is taking a hit for example a study
showed there were just over 2
000 excess deaths in england and wales
due to heart disease and stroke during
the pandemic peak
delayed cancer diagnoses could lead to
almost 3
300 extra deaths in england over the
next five years from four
common forms of the disease and figures
up to the end of august show almost 700
000 jobs have been lost a number that's
only going to rise
now the scientists say it would be
better to go for what they call
focused protection shielding the elderly
and those with
underlying health conditions while
allowing the virus to spread through the
rest of the population who live their
lives as normal
now what's happening on university
campuses is in effect a petri dish for
the theory
locked up in their flat students might
build up herd immunity
the idea is once 50 to 60 percent of
people are infected
the spread of the virus slows the
epidemic wanes
and the vulnerable might be safe to
rejoin the rest of society
but the great barrington declaration has
been ripped apart by
other scientists up to 30 million people
in the uk are at heightened risk from
the virus
and would have to shut themselves away
even then they say
it's impossible to keep the virus out of
care homes and even regular testing of
staff and visitors
is no guarantee of protection more than
14
000 residents died between april and
august
and there are doubts that herd immunity
is even possible only eight percent of
the population has antibodies
well short of what's needed and other
coronaviruses
cause the common cold and let's face it
we get lots of those
until there is a vaccine in widespread
use there will be winners and losers in
whatever governments choose to do
the game changer would be an effective
treatment that reduces the death rate
perhaps to the level of something like
flu
then we could relax about the virus
spreading but for now
scientists are split on what to do